depuis de trop nombreuses années les
partis politiques classiques qui se
gouverne à tour de rôle manu politique
entre guillemets dites raisonnables il
faut rester il faut être raisonnable on
ne peut pas dépenser ce qu'on n'a pas le
pacte de stabilité j'en passe et des
meilleurs effectivement je ne dis pas
qu'il faille jeté l'argent par la
fenêtre
mais tout ça dans un contexte économique
dramatique 25 millions de chômeurs en
europe
alors on vient de déclarer un état
d'urgence en france l'europe dit
effectivement il faut maintenant se
protéger il faut se doter de moyens y
compris financier pour mieux armer la
police plus de policiers plus d'armée et
c'est là on compte pas les deniers mais
on nous sommes en situation de guerre
économique
il aurait fallu un plan marshall pour
lutter contre le chômage contre la
précarité et cetera et que fait que font
parce que là aussi c'est pas la faute de
l'europe autant que les institutions que
font les états ils font ce moment de ne
rien avoir et donc cette politique en
tout cas perçu comme tel 2 du lait la
politique des copains et des coquins je
te file ma plage tard film tu me
pardonneras tout ça pour faire re le
soutiennent de castanet en espèces de
casse celle entre eux soins et bien on
arrive à de tels résultats